when you think of flying animals what do
you think of birds butterflies or bees
might first come to mind but what about
spiders even though they don't have
wings it turns out that spiders are
actually some of nature's best aviators
so how do spiders take to the skies
[Music]
lightning storms are one of nature's
most powerful displays of Earth's
electricity but even under normal
weather conditions electricity is all
around us
the atmosphere holds a positive electric
charge while Earth's surface holds a
negative charge
just like with magnets similar charges
repel away from each other and opposite
charges attract this interaction creates
something called an electric field the
force of this electric field is what
allows for some spiders to defy gravity
in a remarkable behavior called
ballooning it typically begins at high
pointy areas or the Earth's electric
field is the strongest first a spider
drops an anchor silk to secure itself
then it raises its two front legs in the
air and uses special fine hairs to sense
wind and electrical conditions sort of
like a built-in weather station if the
conditions are right
the spider then tiptoes on its back legs
raises its abdomen and releases its silk
to the air
the silk strands are charged which
causes them to repel away from each
other rather than tangling this form of
static electricity is just like what
happens to your hair after rubbing it
with a balloon now ready to set sail
the spider breaks off its anchor line
and the lifts into the air using the
force it gains from the electric field
and wind once airborne spiders likely
use their legs to balance or control
speed during their dangerous journey
most of these trips are short but some
can last for thousands of miles drifting
along with wherever the breeze tastes
them there is still a lot to learn about
why certain species of spiders take to
the skies and scientists are still
gathering clues about how spiders use
electricity to perform this
gravity-defying feat what other shocking
secrets could these spiders still reveal
[Music]
you